vamos a seguir haciendo el primer
problema del examen de 2008 de cálculo a
p el curso que les conté ya habíamos
hecho la parte así que ahorita toca
hacer la parte b déjenme escribir por
aquí arriba la parte b la parte me dice
lo siguiente dice que la línea
horizontal ye igual a menos 2 divide a
la región r recuerda que esta de acá es
la región r en dos partes escribe pero
no evalúe una integral que exprese el
área de la región r que está por debajo
de esta línea recta sale entonces nos
conviene dibujar igual a menos 2 déjame
dibujarla por acá se vería más o menos
algo así es una función constante hay
está creo que no se ve muy bien verdad
deja de hacerlo un poco más grueso con
un color que se vea más a ver ahí vaya
igual a menos 2 queda algo así y
entonces lo que nos dice el problema es
que esta región queda dividida en dos
partes la superior y la inferior
lo que quieren saber es una expresión
integral para el área de r que está
debajo de la recta de igual a menos 2 lo
que nos preguntan es el área de esta
región la que estoy sombreando recuerda
que sólo quieren que encontremos una
expresión lo que le evaluamos con un
poco de suerte eso nos va a ahorrar algo
de tiempo como le hacemos para encontrar
esta expresión lo fácil va a ser
encontrar la expresión que está dentro
de la integral déjame poner la integral
de saber que tenemos que poner aquí en
medio queremos sumar todas las pequeñas
áreas justo como lo hicimos en la parte
a entonces lo que estamos haciendo es
sumar las áreas de muchos rectángulos la
altura de cada rectángulo va a ser este
segmento de aquí y este segmento mide la
diferencia entre las dos funciones esta
es igual a menos 2 y esta de aquí abajo
es igual por aquí lo teníamos verdad x
al cubo menos 4 x
esta curva de aquí abajo entonces la
altura de cada uno de estos rectángulos
flaquitos va a ser igual a menos 2
- x al cubo menos 4 x esta de ahí es la
altura de cada uno de los rectángulos
pero el ancho de cada uno de los
rectángulos sabemos por lo que hemos
hablado acerca de cálculo es que es una
muy pequeña cantidad que se que le
estamos llamando de x verdad y lo que
queremos hacer es sumar de aquí acá
queremos encontrar los límites de
integración es decir este valor de x que
va a ir acá y ese otro valor de x que va
a ser el límite superior entonces estos
de aquí son los puntos en los cuales
estas dos funciones o las gráficas de
estas dos funciones se intersectan cómo
le hacemos para encontrar estos puntos
pues vamos a plantear una ecuación lo
que queremos es encontrar los valores de
x los valores de x para los cuales x al
cubo menos 4x es igual a menos 2
en qué valores de x el valor de g es el
mismo entonces esto de aquí es una
expresión polinomio vamos a pasar todo a
la izquierda para igualarlo a 0 y nos
quedaría x al cubo menos 4x + 2 igual a
0 y aquí te voy a contar un pequeño
secreto ahorita que estaba haciendo la
primera versión de este vídeo intentar
resolver este polinomio sobre la marcha
pero la verdad me quedó debiendo un buen
rato y pensé vaya sí que está difícil y
la verdad no me salió intente factorizar
y salían las cuentas así súper feas
entonces empecé a sospechar un poco y
dije vamos a ver las instrucciones
déjame enseñarte las mira lo que dice es
lo siguiente la solución de algunos
problemas o algunos incisos puede
requerir de una calculadora gráfica hay
entonces dije seguro en este problema
quieren que usemos una calculadora
gráfica entonces que dice pues bueno voy
a sacar aquí mi calculadora gráfica
mirabaje este que es un emulador de una
texas instrumento de y 85 entonces
vamos a utilizar esta calculadora para
encontrar las soluciones de este de esta
igualdad entonces vamos a aprenderla
entonces quiero que veas más o menos que
estoy haciendo voy a elegir la función
bold y entonces aquí se compone nos
preguntan por el orden del polinomio es
decir el grado entonces hay que ponerle
enter y ahora lo que nos preguntan son
los coeficientes el coeficiente en x al
cubo es 1 vamos para abajo el
coeficiente en x cuadrada pues mira no
aparece x cuadrada entonces como no
aparece x cuadrado el coeficiente es 0 y
ahora vamos al coeficiente lineal cuál
es el coeficiente de x el coeficiente en
x es menos 4 entonces aquí tengo que
poner menos 4 y el coeficiente libre el
coeficiente libre es 2 verdad entonces a
0 es igual a 2
ahora le voy a aplicar aquí sol
es decir resolver ahí está pensando la
calculadora y mira obtuvimos tres
números que están así super feos
esto es una pista de que no íbamos a
poder resolver la ecuación
analíticamente bueno al menos no en el
tiempo que nos dan pero vamos a ver hay
tres puntos de intersección pero nuestro
dibujo sólo tenemos dos como le hacemos
para encontrar los dos que nos interesan
pues vamos a ver x 1 es menos 2.2 1 pero
está fuera del dibujo entonces ese valor
de ahí no nos interesa seguro por acá en
la izquierda baja la curva intersectar
llegó a la menos dos también intersectan
1.675 que pues cuál de ellos era pues
parece ser que es el segundo verdad voy
a ponerle por aquí bueno ahorita le
pongo pero el tercer valor es punto 539
entonces lo que podemos hacer es usar
esos valores como límite inferior
y como límite superior entonces déjame
escribirlo aquí en el dibujo este punto
que estoy marcando fuerte nuestra
calculadora nos dijo que es igual a
punto 539 voy a ponerlo como límite
inferior punto 539
y este punto de acá
este punto de acá es el otro valor que
nos dio la calculadora verdad el 1.6 y
cachito deja checo cuál era
ok esté aquí era 1.675 entonces vamos a
ponerlo en el límite superior 1.675 y
nos dijeron que no querían que
evaluaremos entonces ya terminamos ya
encontramos una expresión que nos da el
área que nos piden yo creo que esta
simplificación de aquí a lo mejor
todavía se podía hacer y así pero me
sorprendería mucho que no estuviera bien
el problema bueno vamos a pasar a la
parte se va parte ce entonces lo que nos
dice es la región r es la base de un
sólido para este sólido cada corte que
lo atraviesa y que es perpendicular al
eje x determina un cuadrado encuentra el
volumen de ese sólido ok esto son
interesante vamos a hacer un dibujo si
hacemos la curva perdón la región con un
poco de perspectiva nos quedaría más o
menos así esta es la función seno está
un poco inclinada por porque le estamos
viendo en 3-d y esta de acá es la
función polinomiales déjame dibujo los
ejes verdad con los ejes se va a ver
mucho mejor la perspectiva entonces el
eje
x lo voy a poner con otro color lo voy a
poner con color amarillo es este de acá
es que acabo de dibujar es el eje x
le voy a poner su flechita
ahora vamos a dibujar el eje y va para
allá como ves ya se empieza a ver un
poco más en 3-d
ahora hacemos el eje y para los valores
negativos
voy a poner su flecha por aquí
el eje x el eje y lo que nos dicen es
que esta región
r
justo como lo hicimos en las partes
anteriores hay que hacer una integral
nos dicen que la región r es la base de
un sólido para este sólido cada corte
perpendicular al eje x a ver vamos a
hacer vamos a hacer un corte vamos a ver
si podemos hacer algo así
déjame hacer un corte
supongamos que tenemos un cuchillo y
cortamos perpendicular al eje x entonces
si hacemos un corte algo así lo voy a
poner con amarillo nos dice que es un
cuadrado es decir la altura mide lo
mismo que la base y sube
perpendicularmente a ésta entonces
quedaría algo así esto es como rebanar
un jamón por acá tenemos una rebanada un
poco más pequeña de jamón una rebanada
cuadrada y este lado también tendríamos
una rebanada de jamón cuadrada
creo que más o menos se ve la idea
entonces lo que quieren que hagamos es
encontrar el volumen de este jamón o de
este sólido pues entonces lo que hay que
hacer es sumar todos estos cuadrados
cómo le hacemos para encontrar esto pues
la idea es muy similar al inciso a y b
lo que hay que hacer es tomar el área de
cada uno de estos cuadrados ahorita
vamos a ver cómo encontrarla y ya que
encontramos el área hay que sumar todas
esas áreas por más la quitas que sean es
decir tenemos que hacer una integral de
0 a 2 si ya se me está acabando el
tiempo lo dejamos para la próxima y en
el siguiente vídeo vamos a ver las cosas
con más calma